[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vraiment sa chance et bon goût très bien
merci d'ailleurs très content d'être là
très content d'être là les lula la non
là c'est sacha
nikos
lui croyait fous ces
formations immédiat oui
boufettas ce soir en direct sa carte
gold cup et tout ce qui se passe pendant
les pubs en allemagne et aux play off
c'est parti les loups riba
salut salut salut les loups c'est ça
quand tu call it said they pmp et on
commence tout de suite avec qu'elle est
toujours aussi calé en politique
alors ça me fait extrêmement plaisir
alors qui est un appareil parce que
français
on continue avec matthieu delormeau
gratteur tome 1 pouces présente rentrée
pour voir la pièce laurent laurent
roland
renard français d'accord
ok vous le savez baba et généreux il est
aussi lucide ça va mieux
merci d'apple et suivez vous allez avoir
un cadre tout ça ce soir
c'est pakalolo fou mais c'est pas mal
autant dire que moi qui connais mieux
papa c'est jean-michel aujourd'hui c'est
votre anniversaire alors pour cette
nouvelle année qui s'offrent à vous
qu'est ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter au
dessus de leurs moteurs tome 2
subitement
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup
[Musique]
vous vouliez que joue la roma joue pas
possible
si on reste au lot
après qu'alstom ça castagne découvrez
genton sa baston
pour ce jour attristant j'en ai bien
souvent pas sur notre plateau entre
histoire du mal
décidément il veut stop avec tout le
monde le loup
[Rires]
en tout cas en rien le durcir il fut
toujours autant le contenu des magnétos
il a fait comme ça vous voulez mon avis
soit autre que vous n'existez
l'origine
alors
ça serait pas un petit coquinou ce
bernard
genre j'ai besoin de jouer
mathieu gratteur c'est le dernière
épisode l'épisode 3 gérard je les
connais personne au courant j'aimerais
bien me lancer dans le cinéma là vous
tourner un film bientôt
non pas de tuer comme chaque semaine au
termine avec baba mais qu'est ce qu'on
peut bien le souhaitez pour ce week-end
pécule et qui
l'écouté
on
m'a dit ok c'est guillaume genton il est
complètement à paris alors on les mettre
des médecins gays reste qu'il
fait pas lourd à l'exportation
c'est génial dans quelle émission vois
ça fait mal mon père
m'a rien fait maintenant bleus je la
sens pas votre intervention
parce que je viens pas souvent mais vous
êtes avec jean messia vraiment ou pas
les retours des champions jouent la
baisse alors la fin bon la direccte
dans les années 2020 enfin bon en 1982
c'est con mais c'est sympa vous savez
vous remplissez votre rôle en voilà me
remplacer isabelle ces noms
vous savez voilà merci non mais c'est
pas intervenir dans le mag annie vous
désirez faire intervenir mais avec ma
mission
mention très intelligente quand
[Rires]
tellement de 6 à 7 avec casta
[Musique]
dans un instant cyril c'est le retour
des défis de genton on a vu jean médias
et guillaume genton dans 50 secondes
inside et bien hilares ont fait placer
des mois jean mathias et dans un instant
si je gribouille mais d'abord cyril pour
le prochain magnéto je vous demande
d'accueillir un deux amis proches n'ont
pas l'analyse enfance famille salomé
d'enfance qui travaillent avec vous non
non oui alors est expliqué dans le
connaissent le nombre de liens mais
c'est un ami alors c'est pas du tout on
a mis son nom mais je te le dis on
l'accueille condamné non mais non mais
je pense que j'en ai marre d'entendre ça
alors qualifié alors mon ami ça n'est
pas sexy du concept un ami d'un ami d'un
ami wiki à peine plus âgés que moi et
vous voyez tous les jours avec un ami
d'un ami tous avec moi est un ancien
trader nantes
a ouvert le moule est maintenant entre
leurs cachettes à dire qu'ils vont dès
que du catcheur oui tu vas
tu as du salami catcheur duchesne sellem
tu vas tu vas coutu et saint cricq voilà
et donc non j'aime beaucoup et c'est
vrai que c'est un ami d'un ami qui
travaille maintenant avec moi voilà qui
est devenu par transitivité un ami ban
doit accueillir la vie c'est un petit
peu comme mon grand frère
domaine vous êtes un peu dur à mon père
oui il est là applaudissements
c'est vrai
bonjour n'est pas on a dépeint soir tout
le monde tout le monde est prêt à
concéder ravines où on est non on est
amis d'amis d'amis n'a ni de quoi
attention pour moi je veux dire un ami
m'a fait beaucoup de cadeaux avec moi
des cadeaux parce que
les spectateurs s'ils étaient amis dans
un instant ils en seront plus et bien
sûr que vous avez une belle croissance
tous les deux
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
fait beaucoup balade avec le japonais de
blanche neige
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et aux femmes arrivées très beau oui
je suis allé à fort boyard il a faim car
que le savent pas yann qu'attend on
travaille avec nous depuis deux ans fin
on est avec nous des branches de soi
c'est un joli c'est comme c'est comme
mon grand frère au liban on est plus
grand frère c'est tu ne fais partie
d'une bande d'amis que je connais et
voilà je l' ai recueilli parce que
il est pas bien là j'aimerais bien payer
parce qu'il n'était pas bien il avait
plus de meuf n'avait plus de travail j'y
viens travailler avec moi et elle a gelé
pécho ils étaient travaillés coup les
voilà donc il était avec moi travaillent
avec nous depuis deux ans enfin il est à
mes yeux il est
avec nous et parce qu il est il est
récent il est craquant ils peuvent qui
fait énormément de présence à toi qui
fait acte de présence et c'est déjà pas
mal c'est déjà beaucoup certains y est
normale jeudi avec la wii est là c'est
une qualité mais c'est beau c'est bon
mais c'est vrai c'est beau je reste
vous restez avec nous que tu restes est
toujours présent c'est ton boulot et
présentés au juge pas eh ben c'est vrai
oui en classe on voyait tu viens de
quatre ans je voulais vue c'est bon
pour fêter ses deux ans la société on
s'est cotisé pour lui faire une cagnotte
litchi d'ailleurs au passage et cyril
cagnotte litchi moi j'ai jamais eu de
cagnotte donc si vous pourriez mettre
la garantie limite in kiwi n'ai jamais
rien eu un gagnant
et maintenant qu'on a fait une keynote
richie sauf que on s'est rendu compte qu
autour de cette table il y avait des
gens très généreux mais il y avait aussi
des gros crevard à cyril mois maintenant
[Rires]
[Musique]
résister aux formes et ses tracks et
rien qu'à temps
bien sûr ça fait deux ans qu'il est au
sein des réseaux on a prévu de faire une
cagnotte si l'actuel
plaisir
il est même sous un bon jour
au dernier
il est même franchement moyenne les gens
de la prod il en est à
24 mois je suis généreux
dira si rien n'est trop
crevard et éventuellement dans un
premier temps et me faire plaisir à
dubaï
[Musique]
revin
m
[Musique]
rubin
ah non il sert à rien
gentil pour rien
moi c'est un bon mec
ça lui fait plaisir
il est là on se retrouve lui des
malouins
l alarme
c'était
[Musique]
c'est parce que ça fait deux ans
qu'ils ont envers si
[Rires]
les gages
[Applaudissements]
travaille énormément
je voulais te dire je vais faire cette
cagnotte et franchement à tout cas et
isabelle les prennent d'assaut 950 et
mon frère c'est vrai alexandre guerrier
la haine alexandre
[Applaudissements]
musique chaque fois que quelqu'un avait
su rebondir et qu'on a dû inviter tous
et ça non mais franchement on dirait
qu'ils envisageront on dirait que ça
annonce ryan gosling j'en ai battus de
musique est douce et alexandre carrier
les makes
mais sans déconner on dirait que ça dans
ce débat
[Applaudissements]
tu es donc quand on soit d europe le
matin ils mettent les invités de magma
thème 14 à me sentir bien
avec de petits musées ont
déconné bon alors on a fait une rigolade
avec mon chéri parce que même lui j'ai
vu dans ses yeux qu'il n'y croyais pas
du tout à cette affaire
je le voyais bien et bravo tu es
magnifique et ya dégagé cette cagnotte
merci il mérite cette cagnotte qui fait
un énorme travail je sais pas s'il a un
autre travail ou sur lequel on travaille
mais ici aussi travaille énormément et
je vais vous dire c'est souvent les gens
qu'on ne voit pas travailler qui
travaillent le plus et yann ont mené le
bel exemple merci oui bien sûr je
raconte pas ce qu'on a fait dimanche
dernier par hasard parce que vous n'avez
rien vu dans le canyon n'allait pas bien
un centime avec les copains dimanche
dernier vous avez rien mis dans la
cagnotte bout et l'auberge ça vous
rappelle pas les noms c'est rien mais
j'en ai conduit alors à hollywood j'ai
vendu ce blouson la semaine dernière
les crevasses que j'ai fait un vide
greniers
je vais vous montrer voilà il a fait
l'argent la tête alors oui et j'ai fait
une brocante ça fait combien coffin rien
du tout je veux gagner 40 euros par don
was
comment j'ai gagné pardon au maquillage
monde en parle oui je suis gentil moi
cette faute est gentil mais vous serez
gentil mais direz ça fait le basselin
dit oui la rédac bonsoir
alors que se passe-t-il bon sorcier oui
bonsoir cyril on l'a vu dans le 50
secondes insight tout à l'heure qu'il y
avait des petites une petite histoire
d'amour entre guillaume genton et
genlissiens eh bien figurez-vous que
guillaume genton a récidivé et a fait
placer des mots à agent les siens alors
il ya eu sur ces news ya eu dans tpm et
figurez-vous que là il n'a fait en
direct pendant l'émission regardez bien
comment jean messia est fier quand il
arrive à placer les mots de guillaume
genton là on a passé un step
on comprend la nécessité non seulement
c'est un buzz longueur de temps des
amours avec nouvelles reliques et
l'instrumentaliser fouet la réalité
c'est qu'on avait atterri zemmour c'est
le sens du gouvernement d' emmanuel
macron depuis maintenant 50 m dans le
gouvernement d'union où il stationne
genesis lorraine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais ça n'en est pas du tout donc le
sondage c'est mr le cdh olsen jazz dans
le président est crédité de vente cours
entre 23 et 26 %
[Musique]
mais chassez le père fouras beaumont
tarte aux pommes on l'a vu
[Musique]
la signature des mots
vous lui dites pas que il manque de
courage avec les termes que vous avez vu
qu'on appelle les tripes à la mode de
caen ça je vais te dire pourquoi
[Musique]
il m'arrivait
je suis pas du tout c'est d'après jean
les deux garçons se sont jouées saison
malterre légaux
merci c'est tout
[Rires]
oui cyril avant de repartir j'étais
obligé de parler de vous parce que vous
avez une réputation d'avoir une bonne
mémoire vous enregistrez pas les numéros
de téléphone n'oubliez pas de prompteur
on le dit aux téléspectateurs
maintenant vous avez une bonne mémoire
et cette semaine nous recevait philippe
lellouche et on a revu sa première télé
avec sa coupe un peu approximative un
peu paradoxal c'était la première fois
vous voyez ça rique oui c'était les
bains en fait non pas du tout
c'est un bâtard toi
[Musique]
la première fois qu'on m'a vu à la télé
j'avais une coupe de cheveux autres mike
brant et mireille mathieu
le karaoké devenu un véritable phénomène
de société il ya cinq ans comptent
appliquer à débarquer en force nous
attend
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
estimant qu'il avait jamais vu cette
image alors on a un petit on a
regardé regarde qu'eux on peut dire
aujourd'hui que le karaoké devenu un
véritable phénomène de société à 50 en
[Applaudissements]
si on peut applaudir sociale